bethany is with us in
scranton pennsylvania hi bethany welcome
to the show how can we help
hi uh thank you so much for taking my
call sure
um i have a question so my husband and i
have three very small kids
and our middle child has down syndrome
so we are just wondering what you would
advise for
the future um we recognize that college
may be a possibility but it may not be
um so you're just wondering what you
would do
different to say for her future and then
would you save the same monetary amount
per kid
um no equal is not fair and fair is not
equal
right okay and so if this child needs
more money set aside than the other two
then uh to take care of them then that's
there's nothing wrong with that at all
matter of fact that would be called
being a good parent
and so you're not you don't have some
moral obligation to dole out
everything equally um
the uh uh so you know
what we're gonna do is you're just gonna
save the money in your name
okay and you're gonna have life
insurance
on you and your husband okay and in both
cases the life insurance beneficiary is
going to be named
to the family trust that is formed upon
your death
okay you need to get a lawyer and get a
will built or go to mama bear legal
forms and get a will built it depends on
how complicated your estate is but
you're just getting ready to get pretty
complicated
so what you normally do for a special
needs child there's a special needs
trust
which lasts their entire life and the
trustee is in charge of investing the
money
and handling the money to take care of
the child
okay and they do it according to your
directions and so if this were my child
i would have a special needs trust
that's formed upon my death
and my wife's death and it's funded with
the money from the life insurance policy
that's the beneficiary on the life
insurance policy says x
number of dollars out of this policy
goes in the special needs trust
okay okay and i'm gonna put it across
four types of mutual funds growth growth
in income aggressive growth and
international and the income
produced off of this fund is to take
care of this child and that is the
trustee's job
you would also name a guardian to the
extent that the child as an adult
is not able or is able to take care of
themselves
might be it might be a sibling okay
okay something like that now it with
children that are not special needs
and they're minors we always build a
family trust
and the same exact thing the life
insurance proceeds go into the trust
upon your death if both of you
die okay and or your mutual funds and
investments that you already have go
into
that trust in the event that both of you
die and it works exactly the same way
the only difference is that when the
child reaches a certain age that the
money's just released to them because
they're adults and they're on their own
and you don't need a trust you know a
family
a childhood trust surviving to that kid
65
with special needs you may right
it's the only difference is the length
of time the thing survives they work
exactly the same way
so if you put 500 000 in there and the
thing makes 10
that gives 50 000 a year to take care of
that kid
right that's simple okay
and you can put the 500 000 in there
with investments over time
but until you have that 500 000 you
would have 500 000
worth of your life insurance allocated
to that
and i just made that number up but just
i would just say
take 10 and use that as your number it's
probably not right but it's close enough
okay and and say you know all right i
want them to have
3 000 a month well that's 36 000 a year
so that's 360 000 so let's just call
that a 400 000
policy okay and i'm going to get a
million dollars on your husband and you
and if something happens to you 400 000
is going into special needs
kids trust and the other 600 000 is
going over here
for the other two three hundred each and
they've got very similar
wording and so forth okay
make sense it does i think so yeah it's
um so how severe is the downs
well i mean we don't know she's two oh
you okay yeah you don't have indication
yeah we have a
we have a long time to go so she's only
two um how old are your other kids
um my oldest is four and i have a
two-year-old and a one-year-old
wow oh you are in it aren't you yeah
yes and you're calling me about a well
yeah
oh my goodness yeah so well yeah i mean
even just to set aside for college
yeah like it feels i don't know what to
do for her i would not set aside for
college i would just keep it in your
name
okay because you can control it that way
and you can do with
what you want if you put it into their
name you might lose control of it when
they turn
21 the courts might take it and take it
over to manage it for the kid
and it's not their money it's your money
yeah
okay and you're not going to do anything
that's not for the benefit of the kid
no no we just i we know for us
everything's a little bit slow
uh financially we're not um we're just
yeah so
you'll get there yeah you're gonna get
there because you're thinking about it
and you're being intentional